un retorno triunfal el jueves el ex
presidente de bolivia evo morales fue
recibido por una gran multitud cuando
aterrizó en el aeropuerto de el alto
miles de personas se reunieron para
celebrar en la segunda ciudad más grande
de bolivia agitando banderas wiphala que
representan a los indígenas de los andes
y al partido político de morales
[Música]
ese programa económico
políticas
los grandes
[Música]
las protestas aquí hace más de una
década ayudaron a allanar el camino para
que morales se convirtiera en el primer
presidente indígena en el país en 2006
es la primera vez que regresa el alto en
más de un año después de abandonar
bolivia bajo una nube de sospechas en
noviembre de 2019 observadores
internacionales identificaron
irregularidades en una elección que le
dio un cuarto mandato morales ha negado
repetidamente el fraude una repetición
de estas elecciones en octubre de este
año arrojó la victoria a louis arte
aliado suyo morales se reunió con el
nuevo mandatario y su gabinete en la paz
el hombre de 61 años regresó del exilio
en noviembre después de que arte jurará
como presidente